le grand magazine américain time croit
pouvoir cette semaine affirmé qu'au
cambodge depuis que les khmers rouges
ont pris le pouvoir il y aurait eu des
centaines de milliers de morts mort de
faim d'épuisement massacrés et c'est un
véritable génocide compte tenu de la
population cambodgienne ce serait pire
que ce qu'on fait les nazis et tout cela
en quelques mois les scènes décrites par
times sont atroces de quoi indigner la
conscience des nations si cette
expression voulait dire quelque chose
ces scènes que reprend le times sont en
fait décrite par des cambodgiens
réfugier en thaïlande et qui ont fuit le
pays des khmers rouges d'après the un
demi million de cambodgiens auraient
péri en un an exécutez mort de faim ou
malade et mal soignée des familles des
villages ont été massacrés des hommes
ont été enterrés vivants par des
bulldozer des serait la vérité il en est
une autre celle que présente le
gouvernement khmer qui a fait diffuser
ce film les premières images depuis que
le pays s'est refermé sur lui-même
réalité toute différente où le peuple
joyeux participants repiquage du riz est
soignée travail dans la joie les
réfugiés affirment eux qu'ils n'y a pas
que la population de phnom penh qui a
été contrainte d'émigrer mais que tout
un peuple a été déraciné qu'il est mal
nourris mal logés et forcé à des travaux
harassants quelle est la vérité un
diplomate suédois invitèrent plein de
peine s'est contenté de dire que
visiblement ce n'était pas le bonheur il
n'était resté quand vie seul le
témoignage de journalistes libres de
visiter le cambodge pourrait faire
connaître la vérité les khmers rouges ne
le veulent pas autorisant toutes les
rumeurs il ne présente pour se défendre
que des films de propagande ou comme
toujours les enfants les écoles chante
et riz
à